what is up everybody Welcome to the
100th episode of visual effects Artistry
act we made it you heard of Steven
Seagal
you well after this one
we make a case for why the song Green
sleeves should be renamed to Blue
sleeves because we're watching The
Addams Family and Wednesday where the
thing hand guy is in it and he's cool
we're gonna be taking a look at the
intro to Severance this is just
Instagram reels yeah
there's actually one really simple trick
that is impossible to replicate in real
life and don't forget guys I think what
could be the most exciting part of this
there is a spinning piece of cardboard
that's going to blow your mind
seen the front of the couch a whole lot
seen the back of the couch yeah surprise
guys
they've been working on what's back here
since the beginning of the show and I
think it's time to finally reveal what's
back here
[Music]
thank you to betterhelp for sponsoring
this video keep watching to find out how
you can get 10 off therapy today these
are the 10 types of magic you've
probably seen this clip you guys have
probably seen this right yeah yeah seen
it Kevin Perry's insane 10 types of
magic it's wonderful let's just watch it
levitation yep the Apex are these
actually the ten types of magic I think
I base that on nothing
transformation he's so good oh he's a
pro
transposition that's just so fun man
penetration the penetration I feel like
I could weirdly do but I'm sure I'm
wrong
yeah
that's crazy
predictions then the last one is nice
you shift he's like I just you shifted
my shirt yeah and I'm like come on yeah
after
after all different I'm sitting here
like pulling my hair out trying to
figure out how you do this and you're
like Anna you shifted my shirt it's like
ah
some of these you're like oh this is
like just a magic trick but or are they
does he actually know how to do magic
with Kevin Perry I'm not sure if he has
traditional sleight of hand training
Kevin has done a lot of stop-motion work
he did work at Leica Studios oh this is
that Kevin okay cool I've seen his other
stuff around have you seen the behind
the scenes of his like breakdowns on his
channel like once you watch those it
starts to make this make sense does he
do it behind the scenes of this not that
one but he does others and like you'll
see
oh hey run from the future here check
this out so since filming this episode
Kevin actually released a behind the
scenes look at how he actually did all
of these tricks it's a great video I
recommend you checking it out but in the
meantime let's see how well these guys
are at guessing how Kevin did these
tricks because like is this just match
cut city are we actually just watching
some of like the world's best match Cuts
think about a match cut it's like making
something disappear you want a motion to
smell the eye so you're thinking almost
yeah those big motions are so that
someone can place something in his hand
and paint them out on the side yeah and
likewise he's moving and maybe he's not
pixel perfectly in the same spot but
when it's all in motion you don't even
notice that he's maintaining the same
velocity he was hands moving a certain
speed at the end of one shot he has the
same speed going into the next shot
these are like super basic fundamentals
just done extremely well you know but it
still doesn't explain this first cup gag
unless it's just CG or stick paint out I
bet what's happening there it probably
is on a stick or something like that he
does this but the actual animation of it
moving is a new element yeah so it's
just it's real in the same when he is
holding it and let's go and it's
disappeared and replaced and then it's
real again when he grabs it another
thing that I think really helps with his
work is that he is looking at his
monitor and his feedback and you can see
like onion layers and you have images
stacked on top of each other you can see
how things line up and just lets you be
in the perfect spot and just a lot of
good practice with your body and like
how to move consistently that's the
majority of the work is the lineup for
that kind of transition work also I
think he has to be really careful with
the wrinkles the bottom of his shirt
don't get messed up he stands up and
sits back down he's got to put those
wrinkles right back to where they are if
you wash those wrinkles or the courses
video that'll help probably tell us
what's happening in fact I just saw them
wiggle left side or right side right
there just near his like belly button oh
yep yeah that shirt popped there I kind
of want to watch it one more time and
just watch his face because that would
be the hardest thing is like you can
line yourself up but to match the exact
expression like the musculature
oh yeah yeah right there it's so small
it's so smooth like just watching the
face like you'll notice that there's
like a well also like notice he's like
he changes his expression on the Beats
when the match Cuts happen like he's not
like freezing and then like trying to
hold a frozen expression he's like going
like and look yeah you know in a way
it's like the biggest thing here outside
of his shirt changing color is being a
big misdirection I think a lot of the
magic is it's him it's the match cuts on
him it's like he's got these objects in
his hands that you're looking at and
what he's really doing is misdirecting
you from noticing any little pops or
changes because he as a human being is
there and constantly moving and changing
things and he's doing such a great job
of hiding that what I would love for the
behind the scenes to show on this is
that he's actually got 266 shirts of
various colors
the whole video with stop motion cutting
his desserts oh my God that'd be
incredible this is very very very well
done yeah well done Ken incredible yeah
absolutely pretty incredible
hey guys we're taking a quick break from
react so I can tell you about today's
sponsor better help you know I've done
therapy in the past and recently it's
become quite difficult to actually find
time to go out and actually visit a
person in real life and that's what I
love about better help for those of you
who don't know betterhelp is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online but it's something that I've
never used before so I figured it'd be
really cool to speak to somebody
in-house who is actively using better
help and that is Griffin oh absolutely
dude gosh it's been like six seven
months now and it's been really great
what kind of things are you curious
about is I guess my main concern in
switching over is not feeling like it's
actual therapy I guess when you're not
in person with somebody do you feel like
you're missing anything what I've been
getting is real therapy you know I work
with someone she's a professional it's
someone who I can talk to and get advice
someone who will help me talk through my
issues and you know sometimes even give
me like little homework assignments or
or things to check back in on next week
so I'm getting a lot of the same
benefits as in-person therapy in the
therapy process one of the hardest
things I found was finding someone who
fit me and having to go out in person
and meet the these people it's like what
was the process for finding the right
therapist for you honestly that was one
of the biggest appeals to me I was kind
of going through a lot at that time in
my life and I was really really
overwhelmed and the way betterhelp does
it is you answer some questions and then
they actually pair you with someone you
know you can book a session you can chat
with them if it's not really a fit if
you don't feel like you're clicking you
can switch to another therapist and just
try you know try out different
therapists and there's no real life
limit and you you know you're not gonna
get like a penalty or anything like that
that's really awesome one of the things
that I did see about better help that
was very attractive to me is how many
therapists they have they have like
thirty thousand um so I mean based on
odds alone like you've got to find
someone I got matched up with a
therapist who's a really good fit for me
and has really helped me out a lot over
the last six seven months I'm very
grateful for her how often do you meet
with her I meet with her once a week I
also get access to all these like group
sessions for the price it's a really
good deal especially when you compare it
to traditional in-person talk therapy
well I mean all the excuses that I've
made for not going to in-person therapy
appeared to have been addressed here so
I don't think I have many excuses to not
give it a shot and if you guys are also
interested in giving it a shot we have a
link down below it's betterhelp.com
Corridor crew for 10 off your first
month and that is help better help help
in case you needed help spelling it you
guys go do that I'm gonna get some
coffee because I'm about to watch some
Steven Seagal clips and I feel like I'm
gonna need a little boost yeah you might
need therapy after that man
all right it's a miserable night I know
darling children put down that antenna
oh yeah it's about time we're talking
about the classic thing
[Music]
think of it thing
this came out in 1991. tell me how they
did it oh simple I'm man
with a man with a green sleeve sleeve
green sleeves green sleeves there was a
song written about this man
by the mamushkas
yes every Christmas we uh we sing about
how good the VFX and The Addams Family
are
oh it looks like there's almost some
makeup around the wrist there yeah I
would imagine they'd almost feed it into
like a foe like his that's not his wrist
obviously because you've got the top of
it I'm pretty sure it's a hand with like
a fake wrist that pops out and then it's
being controlled underneath it Blended
there green sleeves out the back yeah
Morticia Morticia and then that one's
the best one of all
right
yeah hold a little hole in the table so
yeah I think this is done by LM so you
are actually looking at digital
compositing from like the only company
that could do it back then until Mayo
brothers freed it for everybody change
the game you just have really nice
background Replacements because a lot of
it is a dude with like a sleeve right
you know doing his thing or whatever
like there you know like there's a guy
under the table with his arm's sticking
into it they're selling it right they're
selling that that's not an arm so
showing you under the table that there's
nobody down there of course that's just
a basic VFX shot get a Clean Plate drop
it in later yeah it looks like they're
using the spoon as like the cover of the
same point it's really clever and then
here there's like makeup like they
actually have like a skirt of wrists
yeah that goes over the hole
foreign
[Music]
across the floor we're seeing its
beautiful Reflections in the lacquered
wood that's actually in the scene and
then this last one is not in the scene
yeah so there's a really big issue that
happens when you film something
separately you need to put on a
reflective thing like a floor so you see
how the reflection of the hand on the
floor you see how the pinky and the
thumb don't actually connect to the
pinky and the thumb of the hand yeah
totally that's because they're just
flipping the footage over but the
reflection is actually from an entirely
different perspective and all those
points of contact should line up this is
like the bane of Shadows on green
screens like when you like when you film
somebody on a green screen you need to
put a shadow on them for like the shot
you're copying them into getting the
shadow to like pinned to their feet is
like the same issue with Reflections
yeah it's a pain in the butt so they
just said screw it
honestly whatever
through it whatever yeah yeah it seems
like in a lot of those running shots
across the wood they're framing out the
reflection just after the fingertips
which is really smart so I want to point
something out here if you go back to the
beginning so like if that was a dude
like Rolling Along his arm would be
covering that reflection of the window
but if you go back right before the hand
hits the ground do we see a reflect from
the arm
oh there's the arm oh there's the arm
you can see the arm Jesus Christ
it's amazing what you just don't see
after a while you just give up and just
let it be what it is that's pretty funny
but you're not really thinking about it
because the Shadows are so steep that
your brain just goes oh yeah that's like
the really long shadow
so apparently they did it even better
now I almost don't even want to look at
the one from Wednesday because it's just
it's always a 3D model it's gonna be CG
what that's no I'm pretty dang sure this
is Mr Greensleeves this is Mr
Greensleeves himself yeah you're right
that's a real hand they at least got the
stump looking a little more modeled yeah
the blending is nice too consider it
done
blue sleeves blue sleeves
all right I'll change the lyrics
[Laughter]
oh cool so the stump is real oh the
stump is real well that's what I was
thinking yeah it's like in the I think
even with the previous one they did that
stump prosthetic that pops up yeah
actually I really like that they're
using a practical hand it looks
wonderful why would you ever want a 3D
CG hand as a character yeah that'd be
chaos I like that it's not a complete
departure from the original thing I like
that it's the same character you know
you don't feel like you're like yeah
whatever we don't care about those old
movies the original film is already
impressive this takes the same
techniques and all that and does it
actually better yeah and it's an actual
Improvement not to say it was ever bad
but yeah it's it's pretty amazing
Severance everyone says the show's great
oh this Show's the best show
this is my favorite intro is this like a
mobile game ad
look at these dude I know they're like
wacky photo scans yeah this is like
something up your alley Jordan and so is
when I first saw this knowing this is on
the table is like something that they're
allowing in these big shows makes me so
happy
[Music]
this is just Instagram reels yeah
this is just VFX artists this is what my
Instagram feed looks like yeah is this
like a collection of these types of
shots all happening looping Sam do you
know how this came to me what Ben
Stiller who's on Instagram
he saw this guy's real and he's like he
had this weird animation of like babies
coming out of a brain and like turning
into jelly I thought this is amazing so
he worked with us over the course of
time
his name do we have his name
Instagram reel Oliver Lots
I have been following this guy for years
on Instagram I love his stuff yeah and
when I found it it was him who made it I
can't even describe the joy so you know
these are like kooky photo scans with
some like cloth Sims on top but there's
outside the wacky physics Sims and the
photo scans there's kind of one other
effect at play that makes this visually
compelling can you guys name it can you
spot it can you figure it out
orthographic perspective boom Sam got it
wow
well it's not all of the shots yeah yeah
this isn't but a lot of them have it how
would you how would you describe
orthographic orthographic perspective is
basically no perspective here's the
thing there's there's two versions of
reality okay there's the way reality is
and then there's the way that we
perceive it and look at it with our eyes
so like the stairs back there okay to
your eyes they're gonna look smaller
than me but in reality they're actually
larger and it's only because of the way
you're viewing the relationship of space
between us that's you're getting that
sense of scale but with orthogonal
perspective it is a visual way to make
sure that the true scale the truth
angles relationship of all objects is
how they are based in reality so
basically it eliminates perspective
that's cool so this death shot's a
perfect example notice the desks in the
foreground are the exact same size of
the desks in the background yeah there
is no perspective yeah especially here
as the camera starts to level down now
it looks really everywhere look at the
desks in the background don't they seem
oddly big compared to the desks in the
foreground
oh cool it's very trippy because it's
subtle because it looks right to your
brain but it also looks otherworldly
it's essentially like an infinite Zoom
yeah we're basically even at the same
point Have You Ever Seen The like the
spinning window optical illusion where
like the window appears to spin in One
Direction while like something inside of
it spins in the opposite direction this
is the first part of a three-part
illusion what do you see so this is just
normal looking
yeah or is it so which way is it
spinning left or right
left
at a 50 50 chance this is a good example
where it's like you take a camera you
kind of Zoom it in so you kind of get
the orthogonal look then something's
drawn to look like it has vanishing
point perspective it looks like it just
Wiggles back and forth because that wide
Edge feels like it's always in front the
skinny Edge feels like the back is you
know Vanishing right right but that's
not the case at all
it's doing a full 360. wow yeah this is
it gets really trippy here especially I
love this yeah the lighting needs to be
really even on both sides to convince
you that it is
yeah it's like clipping it looks like
it's clipping right it's that's crazy
you take this and then you combine this
with a bunch of really cool physics Sims
and cool renderings and cool like artsy
photo scans and you throw in like the
orthogonal perspective and then you get
something really special so yeah well
done Oliver yes very very well done good
good stuff good stuff keep going
I thought you said No weapons no I said
no guns
this is code of honor okay the esteemed
Steven Seagal yeah yes and you know Matt
and I were currently working on putting
Steven Seagal in John Wick something no
one asked for we're gonna turn him into
John Legend put him in the John Wick
trailer it's perfect I figure why not
celebrate this monster with with some
clips and I just just play it man oh
great it's fixture itself
oh my gosh yes wow it's there there wait
wait go back run that back did I get the
was there a classic X was there classic
blood X this guy doesn't miss man oh my
gosh that doesn't miss right in your
face just like that they're just like
dragging it out of their folder
no they don't even bring it into their
project bin they drag it directly onto
the screen right in Premiere and it like
loads it and it just figures it out and
they're like cool that exit wound is
quite special isn't it everything about
it yeah the colors like a lollipop
and for one frame they bulged his face
weird it's just like they bulge it out
instead of having the cheek the whole
skull experience I mean actually that's
not uh
terrible idea I guess if you're doing it
you got to give it some impact right
like it's actually the one touch of
artistry in here this compared to like
the dread stuff we looked at I mean
compared to Judge Dredd or like District
nine but this is more like judge
Dreadful
there's a movie based on my
understanding is he's like a vigilante
he's taking down the druggies but he's
quite literally just killing people who
are using drugs
he's like RoboCop
he just murdered people also you can
tell if you go back you can totally tell
that they're darkening the end of the
gun because it's an airsoft gun oh yeah
yeah so there's the inner barrel of an
airsoft gun I'm gonna point this gun at
the camera apologize Don't Be Afraid
everyone there's like the facade Barrel
on an airsoft rifle but then there's an
actual inner barrel that's being used to
actually you know Propel the BBS and
they're tracking a black dot that black
dot is covering up the airsoft inner
barrel that's super funny because yeah
they didn't even like color match like
the haze
black
it just it blows my mind though that
logically he doesn't kill the one person
doing crack there's one person actually
doing drugs she's the one who gets left
let me ask you this question you're on a
rooftop oh you're in danger oh no how do
you escape what's a cool way to get out
of there slide down the Rope shoot a
hole through the ceiling okay what about
this
what he just rolls into the glass I just
hug myself
wow is that a stun did they just drop no
I don't think a guy I don't think he
would have bound starter I think that's
a VFX yeah I think he jumps up and lands
sideways and they just Stitch it yeah
yeah yeah yeah gosh I just couldn't
think of like a less graceful way to do
that but that seems to go all didn't run
from fights
and just in time our heroes arrived
I'm just like oh my gosh standing in the
helicopter standing in the helicopter
with like light glow wrap around them
from no Source like the guy on the right
oh
no
it just hurts to look at oh wait did
they film them like in another area for
a different scene and then just be like
no now they're in the helicopter just
pull them maybe I wonder I think that's
why the comp is so bad is because they
weren't on a blue screen whatsoever
that's protobrush I bet my life on it
yeah oh my God it's a special breed
isn't it that's rough I feel like you'd
find the shot in the movie somewhere
else
it's just special so I want to share
that with you guys we've been diving
down the well of Steven Seagal and we're
fully consumed at this point John sick
comes out tomorrow
subscribe slash come back if you're on a
computer just leave this window open
just leave this tab open until tomorrow
yes as a reminder
[Applause]
I'm exhausted
come on let's check this out all right
let's do it so ever since we started the
show
every single guest we've had
we've had them sign the back of the
couch we got our names on it too yeah we
actually we got me is this you Sam no I
don't think I've signed this wait you
haven't you haven't signed the couch no
what
you guys are witnessing Sam sign the
couch on the 100th episode there it is
baby that's it that's the same
immortalized the very first episode when
you film this it was you and Ren and
Clint and then Carmichael it was the
idea just to kind of to like talk about
how weird Sonic looked and it was like
it was completely off the cuff it's
crazy to have these people who like you
know I've always seen as being these
these Kings on top of these mountains
just be like yeah I like nerding out
about visual effects and you guys like
nerding out about visual effects let's
do it we've had a lot of animators on
the show and a byproduct of that is that
you get really cool drawings like
Patrick Osborne who drew the dog from
Feast yeah mush of the dragon from Tom
Bancroft and Pumbaa from Tony Bancroft
like from the hands of the artists
themselves yeah that's actually really
special it's really pretty cool Captain
disillusions intern
all of these VFX supervisors yeah from
all these different VFX Studios those
who are like you know what you seem cool
enough we'll come and visit you guys to
share the couch with you and it's like
it's really cool pretty cool I want to
say thank you to some of the guests that
helped us kick off some of these genres
of shows I mean every single guest you
have been amazing to have on the show
all of you viewers it's been amazing to
have you watching and learning with us
also thank you to all of you website
subscribers for watching through all of
this stuff you help really make a lot of
this stuff move now this back of the
couch reveal it's special for YouTube
but people on the website they already
knew they saw the back of the couch in
the factual title header of the category
for extended reaction if you like this
show subscribe on Corridor digital.com
because you get to watch half hour
episodes we got our videos at free apps
on the phone smart TV apps you just
watch on your TV we got merch discounts
we've got exclusive shows it's 3.99 a
month all right that's it I'm done